a colossal failure by congressional
Republicans to govern and pass the
President's agenda and keep their
promises it's now forcing President
Trump to seek out alternative ways to
now get things done now what you're
watching unfold here is the failure that
has literally pushed this president into
the arms of Chuck Schumer and Nancy
Pelosi as we have explained on this show
President Trump is moving at lightning
speed he's checking those things off his
list remember the dings last week of the
week before all his campaign promises
one by one Republicans in the House and
Senate have zero sense of urgency no
sense of accountability and even after
promising for years and years and years
they would deliver for you the American
people they have not so with Republican
lawmakers not in his corner
well the president has few options he
can either wait around for Republicans
to get their act together or he can try
to forge ahead with on his own and that
means even reaching out to Democrats so
last night President Trump he met with
Democratic leaders Chuck Schumer and
Nancy Pelosi and of course once it was
over they raced with a press release
saying in part quote tonight leader
Schumer and I had a productive meeting
with President Trump we agreed to a plan
to work out an agreement to protect our
nation's dreamers from deportation we
insisted that the bipartisan DREAM Act
would be the basis for that protection
and that we would review border security
measures that didn't include building a
wall now the president he responded this
morning he tweeted out quote no deal was
made last night on daca massive border
security would have to be agreed to in
exchange for consent now it would also
be subject to a vote the wall which is
already under construction in the form
of new renovation of old and existing
fences and walls will continue to be
built and then this afternoon the
president he responded further and he
shot down the claim that a deal was in
place and that the border wall would not
be built here's the president in his own
words not Chuck and Nancy's why and I do
in fact
we have to have an understanding that
whether it's in the budget or some other
vehicle in a fairly short period of time
the wall will be funded otherwise we're
not doing anything no we're not looking
at citizenship we're not looking at
amnesty we're looking at allowing people
to stay here we're working with
everybody republican we're working with
democrat I just spoke with Paul Ryan
he's on board everybody is on board they
want to do something
we're not talking about amnesty we're
talking about we're talking about taking
care of people people that were brought
here people that have done a good job
and were not brought here of their own
volition
but very importantly what we want we
have to have a wall if the wall is going
to be obstructed when we need the funds
and a little bit later date
will be determining how much we need
then we're not doing anything burnt
we're doing is we're doing it in
conjunction with the Republicans we have
a very very good relationship with a lot
of people a lot of people want this to
happen they expect it to happen and
we'll see if it happens but we'll only
do it if we get extreme security if we
get not only surveillance but everything
that goes along with surveillance and
ultimately we have to have the wall if
we don't have the wall we're doing
nothing if we don't have the wall we're
doing nothing and then he said they were
not talking about amnesty now later in
the day president Trump doubled down
when he got back to the White House
let's look at this
the Democrats are gonna listen we're not
gonna do what they want we're not
talking about Everest at all we have not
talked about
there'll be no evidence we're not
talking about that
dr. now at the wall very soon
now since last night I always suspected
I know the President and at home pretty
well I've interviewed him many many
times I assumed he was negotiating last
night and he needs to continue to set
the record straight
why because Chuck Schumer Nancy Pelosi
closing statement that's beyond
disturbing they are essentially claiming
this that the Democrats they get
everything they want they get daca and
the president doesn't get his wall
here's the one thing that everyone needs
to understand about Schumer and Pelosi
they don't like this president they
can't stand him they want the President
to fail and they certainly don't have
his best interest in heart or in mind
and Schumer in Pelosi they only care
about scoring cheap political points why
because they want to gain seats in 2018
now remember since 2009 Democrats have
been getting destroyed at the ballot box
losing the presidency 13 Senate seats 64
House seats 13 governorships and 33
state houses and as soon as it doesn't
serve them politically I can promise you
Chuck Schumer Nancy Pelosi they're going
to turn around and stab the president in
the back that's a fact also in fact it
wasn't that long ago when Schumer and
Pelosi were just trashing the president
let's remind everybody the president's
decision to end daca was heartless and
it was brainless we all agree that
President Trump's decision to end daca
is a despicable act of political
cowardice President Trump did a tweet
last night and a tweet this morning not
presidential
he doesn't know right from wrong true
from false American patriotism from
white nationalism I'd like to say a few
words about Donald Trump jr.
the emails are the end of the idea
pushed by the administration and the
president that there is absolutely no
evidence of intent to coordinate or
collude Donald Trump is a job leader the
president's fitness for office is
something that is being called into
question I'm very worried about his
fitness now the President as he
reiterated many times today he is
insisting this border wall be built
which he absolutely should be doing
because it was a massive campaign
promise he
he needs to keep his promises I would
argue otherwise there will be severe
political consequences for him and the
entire Republican Party now if the
president doesn't get funding and get it
up front first I'd argue his never gonna
get it let me be clear if the wall is
not constructed the president risks
losing his entire base and it's not a
matter of if the base will leave that's
plain and simple and that by the way is
what Democrats want they want President
Trump to be isolated why so they can
bludgeon him more politically now
President Trump needs to keep pushing
for that border wall and the funding and
he promised you the American people over
and over again that he would get that
built for example remember this we are
building a wall on the southern border
which is absolutely necessary believe me
we have to close down our government
we're building that wall we will build a
great wall along the southern border and
Mexico will pay for the wall women build
that wall build that wall build that
wall build that wall
they said the President of Mexico said
they will not under any circumstances
pay for the wall they said to me what is
your comment I said the wall just got
ten feet higher it's true all right
here's what we are the president must
insist on the complete border wall
funding now or guess what I'd argue it's
never coming now
no one believes that the wall will be
built later if in fact they get their
dock a deal now up front it's the same
old Washington DC sewer swamp game
Democrats love to play this they always
promise spending cuts in exchange for
tax increases but guess what you never
get the spending cuts and you always get
the tax increase and the same goes for
immigration we always get the amnesty
the concession you never get the reform
you never get the border security that's
promised the Democrats they want daca
and then amnesty for all the illegal
immigrants they don't care about the
wall they never have never will
they don't want to build the wall so the
president needs to act with great great
caution here because the Democrats have
burned Republicans over the decades way
too many times with the so-called
bipartisan deals now also if the wall
doesn't end up being built President
Trump he will be put in great political
danger let me give you a quick political
history lesson to illustrate this point
you may remember back in 1988
when then candidate George HW Bush made
this promise during the Republican
National Convention
read my lips a very bold promise and
voters they took George Herbert Walker
Bush at his word propelling him to a
landslide victory over Michael Dukakis
then once he got into office it was a
different story for President Bush and
in 1991 he signed a bill that massively
raised taxes a millions of Americans and
guess what happened while he lost in
1992 to Bill Clinton he didn't get a
second term and I have been warning
about the five big forces that are
working around the clock to destroy and
damage and D legitimize President Trump
and they've been doing it from the
minute he took office
for example the deep state they've been
leaking information that is meant to
damage the president and pretty much we
have a leak a day now no president can
work under those conditions that's
extraordinarily difficult especially
when they're leaking conversations with
prime ministers and presidents then you
have the destroyed Trump media they've
been spewing fake news and creating
black helicopter tinfoil hat conspiracy
theories they've been lying about him
for months no evidence and by the way
they're trying to hurt the president
every day and we have Democrats like
Chuck Schumer Nancy Pelosi and this
bipartisan outreach to me is a charade
right because for months all the
Democrats have been doing is resist
obstruct lie they've even called him a
racist repeatedly and some have even
called for president Trump's impeachment
guess what they want him to fail and you
know what didn't you have the never
Trump errs the establishment Republicans
they have failed miserably every step of
the way so far during the Trump
presidency and you know what sadly they
can't be counted on at this point they
couldn't even get enough votes to repeal
and replace Obamacare a promise they
have been making for seven and a half
years and then Evert rumpus they just
want the president to fail they always
have they always will and they hope the
president fail so miserably so they can
point their fingers and everybody's face
and say we were right I have been
warning about these five forces working
daily against the president it's been
happening from day one now we're seeing
how Republicans and never Trump errs
their inaction their lack of urgency
it's hurting the president's ability to
get his job done he wants to keep his
promises he's done everything he could
do on his own without their help and
make no mistakes the Democrats don't
want this president to keep those
promises that's not good for them my
advice tonight is very simple the
president needs to keep his campaign
promises stick to his agenda the agenda
are things that help The Forgotten men
and women in this country create jobs
lower taxes reform the tax code repeal
replace Obamacare allow those
multinational companies to repatriate
trillions from overseas cut government
regulations which he's done renegotiate
bad trade deals energy independence so
many jobs with energy 4% GDP growth
rebuild the military build the border
wall extreme vetting defeat Isis keep
putting originalist on the Supreme Court
send education back to the States
fix America's crumbling infrastructure I
argue this the key to the president's
ultimate success tonight isn't him
keeping promises that's what the
American people elected him to do if he
does that the economy grows if jobs are
created
if he keeps America strong everybody
wins
and the president and even all those
Republicans that don't support them will
all benefit politically and I want to
show you a few numbers 74 percent of
Americans disapprove of Congress's job
performance and look at the numbers for
congressional leaders Speaker of the
House Paul Ryan well he has the highest
favorable approval rating and that's
only at seventy thirty five percent not
great Chuck Schumer Mitch McConnell
they're in their 20s in his home state
of Kentucky
McConnell's at 18% and these lawmakers
that want to tell the president they're
the ones that want to tell him what to
do I don't think so
now another trap the Democrats I think
of trying to set is on taxes now listen
to what the president said earlier today
so the wealthy Americans are not my
priority my priority are people in the
middle class and that's where we're
giving the big tax reduction to it's
about the middle class and it's about
jobs and it's about bringing jobs back
to the country bringing back the
companies back so that companies can get
a reduction the president needs to avoid
these Democrats and they're pleased to
tax tax tax tax the rich redistribute
wealth and again he needs to remember
the bold Reagan like tax cuts and the
reform he promised all of us take a look
we're here today to launch our plans to
bring back to Main Street by reducing
the crushing tax burden on our companies
and on our workers we have no choice we
must lower our taxes you are honest
hard-working taxpaying and by the way
you're overtaxed but we're gonna get
your taxes down we're giving you the
biggest tax cut in the history of our
country I am proposing an
across-the-board income tax reduction
especially for middle-income Americans
this will lead to millions of new and
really good paying jobs these reforms
will offer the biggest tax revolution
since the Reagan tax reform now the
president needs to follow the plan that
he's already put forward it reminds me a
lot of Reagan you got across-the-board
tax cuts
you got brackets seven-to-three 15
percent corporate tax rate that makes
American businesses so much more
competitive than they are now allow the
multinational corporations repatriate
the trillions of dollars they have
parked overseas let them bring it back
at a lower rate they can invest in
American workers build factories
manufacturing centers for Americans that
desperately need those jobs I mentioned
energy energy independence it's good for
national security it'll create millions
of high-paying career jobs do this he's
already gutted regulations it will
unleash the American economy and
prosperity and growth remember President
Reagan he slashed the top marginal rate
from 70 to 28% and by doing so in the
1980s he created 20 million new jobs by
the way that was after the 80
to recession and government revenue
those people in Washington
well they had almost double what they
had before and it's also a matter of
fairness and simple economics ever
gotten a job from a poor person look at
these statistics now according to the
most recent IRS numbers the top 1% in
this country they paid thirty nine point
five percent of all federal income tax
the top ten percent
they paid 70 point nine percent of all
personal income tax that goes to
Washington now that compares look at the
bottom 50% they pay two point eight
percent combined that's the bottom fifty
and get this thirty five percent of tax
filers they have zero tax liability now
radical left-wing
progressive taxation that distributes or
redistribute wealth it's been proven to
fail again and again it will never work
this is the first major test I would
argue the Trump presidency and has the
potential to make or break it the
president's plan is rock-solid so the
president actually building a wall
following up on his tax plan is so
important that's why the Democrats don't
want him to succeed now if he doesn't
get those things done he'll lose a lot
of his base that would hurt him and the
rest of the Republican Party I would
argue will be in shambles which only
creates more political opportunity for
Democrats they don't want him to succeed
so the President does want to negotiate
what he said today about daca that's
fine the president he's great at
negotiating Republicans they pushed him
into the arms of Pelosi and Schumer they
have failed the president at a very high
level and as a result he's reached out
to these Democrats now this major
campaign promise I would argue
especially funding the wall cutting
these taxes all the tax plans that the
president that I just mentioned that he
wants to put in place those things are
non-negotiable in my opinion the
president wants to negotiate that's
great what he can't do is allow the
negotiation away of funding the wall
he's got to get the funding and get it
first and as President Reagan once said
trust and verify when it comes to the
president he needs to do that with the
Republicans and Democrats get the border
funding first